the word community should be very much
concerned with what happened in haiti in
love with the amount of help that haiti
just received is that how you must help
you to be distributed among the Haitian
people you are such a mess such as its
rate and such of this or organization
that a lot of hair patients die a lot of
people win moving and a lot of kids
probably and waiting to show their
health problems just because the world
community wasn't ready and there was a
lot the center of man that would tell
all the world organizations and medical
teams and from all over the world where
to go what to do where to send the
rescuers and what how to improve the
general situation of the people of haiti
i recommend the world leaders that must
be a central command to the united
nations or through any other source so
when a new haiti disaster occurs in
anywhere in the world we are ready and
prepare to help and could you give all
our support to a nation that needs
everything apart